sorti ce matin du porte parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov dit attendre une
réponse de washington au sujet des deux
propositions de moscou pour tenter de
résoudre la crise en ukraine la
correspondance en russie signé vers la
gauche mais la balle dans le camp des
états unis leur relation trop mou secoué
washington pourrait s'améliorer si la
partie américaine commence l'époque
parlait avec la russie au sujet des
garanties de sa sécurité estime les
autorités russes moi ce qu'on avait
présentée le 12 décembre des
propositions et a demandé l'engagement
des états unis pour bloquer le
déploiement de l'otan vers l'est
notamment vers des pays comme le cren
parmi les autres demandes du kremlin
obtenir la certitude que la collection
ne construisent pas de bases militaires
sur le territoire des pays de l'ex bloc
soviétique
le crin blanc attend toujours une
réponse de la part des états unis a
déclaré dmitri peskov porte-parole du
président russe
il est encore trop tôt pour donner une
évaluation
nous avons bien sûr entendu certaines
paroles mais qui font plutôt référence à
diverses sources concernant la volonté
de mener aux discussions c'est
probablement un facteur positif mais il
n'y a toujours pas de réponse sur le
fond il est donc encore trop tôt pour
donner des estimations c'est prématuré
côté européen on estime que les vingt
sept doivent obligatoirement faire
partie des discussions concernant l'
architecture de la sécurité européenne
selon le chef de la diplomatie de
l'union josep borrell le président
français emmanuel macron s'est prononcé
pour le format non mendier afin de
régler la situation au taux de l'ukraine
la russie quand elle aimerait aussi à
entamer en format bilatéral des
discussions ont pu écouter
les dunes
nous en avons pris note on verra je
confirme ce que nous avons dit la
semaine dernière ce qu'on propose aux
états unis c'est de mener des
négociations bilatérales sur ce sujet
en ce qui concerne les autres formats le
souhait de certaines figures des
représentants de certaines structures
bien sûr nous les prenons en compte mais
cela ne signifie pas que nous changeons
de politique nous continuerons à plaider
en faveur d'un processus de négociations
bilatérales avec washington
les médias occidentaux ont multiplié ces
dernières semaines d'exact isation
l'égard de la russie qu'ils préparaient
une attaque contre l'ukraine moscou a
rejeté à plusieurs reprises ces
accusations et les alliés à la volonté
de le temps de déployer davantage de
matériel militaire près de la russie les
tensions restent vives à la frontière